what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime xbt
they are a crypto trading platform that
has an excellent award-winning
environment for margin trading if you
want to go check out
their crypto trading be sure to check
out their copy trading module which
allows you to replicate the trades of
the most successful traders with a
proven track record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a
50 deposit bonus go check them out at
prime
xbt and let's get into this interview
all right guys bang bang i've got brian
here with me thank you so much for doing
this sir hey it's always a pleasure man
thank you
absolutely let's just jump right into
your background you've got a really
unique perspective
uh on the world based on some things
that you've done and then also
where you're spending time today but
maybe just walk us through where did you
grow up and kind of how did you get into
technology both as a builder and an
investor
sure i'm from the bay area originally a
small town
called sebastopol uh and uh you know i
ended up
getting my car drove from california to
costa rica bought a one-way ticket to
boats at colombia
uh you know there's uh a lot of times a
woman behind these stories i've met my
wife and
my girlfriend in san diego she likes to
say she imported me to colombia
and so i ended up moving to colombia uh
you know chasing the girl
and we ended up getting married and then
three months you know planned to make it
down to patagonia three months in in
both colombia turned into six and a half
years
and uh i basically ended up getting into
tech and entrepreneurship out of
necessity to kind of
continue my my journey down south and so
that's kind of the genesis of uh you
know how i got into building companies
in the region
it's amazing uh and the the good part is
that your story ends well because she
ends up becoming your wife so uh
exactly a positive development to the uh
to the story
uh let's talk about kind of you as an
operator uh in latin america maybe just
walk through a little bit as to what
you've done there obviously you've got a
highly successful business that you
built
um but kind of just walk us through it
sure i mean you know it was a long
journey
right and and it was it wasn't a
straight line to kind of get to
successes
as we all know right and so uh you know
i did everything
in the early days i mean just to pay the
bills i would literally i bought this
like business book or for business
english
because no one would hire me right and
so i literally walked the streets
of both colombia knocking on you know
office buildings and selling my english
classes
um because i need to you know pay my
rent and so that was kind of how i
started off
and uh you know that the ideas kept kind
of increasing
in size over time but i did that in the
first kind of year and a half two years
i hired a teacher because i was like i'm
a terrible teacher and so
uh you know then i started uh you know
getting into kind of uh you know i
actually met my co-founder
paying a fine at immigration services
because we both overstayed our visas
he was from germany i had a student that
wanted to learn german
and so i basically saw him in line
paying this fine i'm like hey
you got a german passport do you want to
teach german classes uh
the guy you know he wanted to keep his
trip going so he ended up
uh you know we didn't end up doing the
german classes but he
and i both had an interest in tech and
we both kind of came up with our first
business which was
more like websites and you know uh not
high-tech
you know entrepreneurship but just like
you know
websites and translation services and
then that kind of evolved
eventually into building my you know
kind of the main startup that
uh worked out for me which is called
viva real a real estate marketplace kind
of like
zillow of brazil is is the way i would
describe it
and and talk about that business a
little bit because uh you're being
incredibly uh humble but uh you raised
tens of millions of dollars for it it's
been incredibly successful so
talk to us kind of what was the impetus
for the idea why that specific market
uh and then kind of how you guys
executed on the business yeah it's a
funny story when i
kind of had the idea for the business i
think it was two major factors one
i was living in a piece of crap uh you
know
hotel motel uh you know by the way uh
motel is different in colombia that i
didn't realize when i first got in
i thought it was like a motel aid but it
was not a great place to be let's just
say that
and when i ended up uh you know wanting
to move out of there because
i frankly my my wife's family you know
girlfriend at the time
dropped me off and they were you know
they were like scolding her for letting
me stay in this
very very kind of dumpy place and so i
you know i ended up trying to find a
place
i went into the classifieds that's how
long ago this was in 2000 kind of five
six and i you know i ended up you know
talking to a real estate agent and the
real estate agent
i got the perfect property for you you
know they were they were you know all
confident on the phone
we sat down in a cafe uh the agent pulls
out a piece of paper from their
briefcase
and says i've got the perfect property
you're looking for um that'll be
10 000 pesos which sounds like a lot of
money but you know that that was only a
few dollars at the time
um and i reluctantly you know i need to
get out of this place i reluctantly paid
the the agent just to see the
information and
spent the whole day first property
already rented
second property too big third property
too expensive
wasted the entire day money time and i'm
like there's got to be a better way and
so
around the same time i read a case study
from mercado libre for the audience that
doesn't know mercado libre it's it's
one of the biggest internet companies in
the world it just kind of touched the
100 billion dollar market cap company
and i came across a stanford case study
that i uh that i you know they read at
an internet cafe
and i thought you know kind of putting
those two experiences together
crappy experience largest asset class in
the world
um and you know amazing business that
kind of touched upon real estate but was
more classified in general
uh that was the the kind of the genesis
for the idea of wanting to start
more of a real estate classified
marketplace business
got it and so once you start the
business uh does it take off right away
do you guys kind of have to tinker with
it and kind of really find product
market fit
how do you eventually get it to where it
sources scale well pomp there was no
uh pomp investors you know uh uh back
then in colombia
you know i didn't have uh access to
capital so
you know i like to say i bootstrapped um
but really
you know that makes it sound fancy that
i decided to bootstrap
there's just no money right so you know
we had to get the customers first
we had to you know we had to uh you know
get create revenue initially because
i got rejected by 30 investors when we
were trying to raise money
this is 2009 when we actually started
the business i had the idea kind of 2000
2008
7 and then we we deployed the website in
2009 but
you know we all know what happened in
2009 right 2008 this is the
you know the backdrop of the financial
crisis so
coupled with the fact that like latin
america is not exactly the hot spot in
around that time the aura of colombia
isn't the first thing you don't think of
is like
tech innovation right we all know kind
of the first thing that happens in the
minds of most people think about
colombia
the image is changing in the country but
back then it was you know it was a
little bit more dangerous and not as
uh traveled to and so we struggled man i
mean we had two and a half years
you know just bootstrapping um kind of
hustling
you know selling you know selling
websites and marketing services and kind
of anything we could
to eventually evolve the business into
more pure play marketplace kind of
classified site um it took us yeah two
and a half years to raise
our first capital and you know 30 knows
and really the breakthrough moment for
me was when i ended up connecting with
two different investors they were angel
investors one of them had
been the former ceo of a company called
rea group which is a 10 billion
market cap company in australia and he
was the ceo during a time of extreme
growth
and he along with another guy by the
name of greg waldorf who used to be the
ceo of eharmony
and was an early i think he was the
first investor in trulia
uh you know the real estate marketplace
in the us that was acquired by zillow
the two of them ended up investing early
on and so
i had zero signals i didn't go to
stanford i didn't go to harvard
uh you know didn't have a network and no
one thought latin america was kind of a
place to be
uh investing and so when they invested
you know greg was a
ceo in residence at uh at excel all of a
sudden it just
popped into this network that i that i
was unfamiliar with and kind of
you know became accepted as oh this
entrepreneur might be onto something and
then the trajectory of the company
changed immediately after that
yeah it's absolutely fascinating uh kind
of how you know once you start to hit an
inflection point and momentum builds
like here we go uh
talk a little bit about as you guys
scaled the business i know there were
some transactions along the way
um but kind of where did the business
eventually get to why did the
transactions and kind of how does the
business look today
yeah so the you know the 2011s we raised
our first kind of institutional capital
we raised from two local investors
the founders of mercado libre spun off
and created a fund
um and so kazakh and then another
top-tier fund called monashis
kind of led our series and then we piled
on some additional growth capital um
spark
uh you know spark invested lead edge and
a handful of other
dragonear valiant and a couple hedge
funds um so we raised about 74 million
dollars of venture
uh scaled the business it was quite
competitive uh we went against
a a tiger-backed competitor um
and who you know in the early days you
know they they were
you know they had raised much more money
than us and were well funded had you
know years of
kind of ahead of us so that was a real
struggle to kind of go head-to-head with
them
and then our other competitor was the
you know the largest media company in
latin america
and i'm not joking when i say that they
basically own the media in brazil
um it's you know i remember when we were
competing and i was in a cafe one day
and you know they have these telenovelas
which are soap operas
and they get super bowl audiences like
every week like this is
and i remember inside the the soap opera
they did a plug for their products are
competing
like they're like you know juan you
gotta go to you know zap
the real estate place you know and it's
like organically in the the soap opera
so
that was terrifying as an underfunded
scrappy entrepreneur
going against this media giant um
we were very scrappy we bootstrapped
hard in the early days so we were very
good with managing our money
and so we were much more efficient in
our growth and we grew organically while
everyone else was spending
big dollars in media and so that enables
us to kind of
you know go to toe to toe with these
larger companies and one thing that i
really knew
pomp was that you know there'd be
consolidation at some point right that's
inevitable in a market like this so i
kind of had the realization
that either you're at the table or
you're on the menu and so my goal was to
make sure
hustling to get at the table and make
sure that we have our deserved spot
there
what ended up happening is there was
consolidation um you know we had
approached the larger incumbent
to try to do a deal it kind of got
laughed off uh for
for a couple years because we were so
tiny as we kind of started
you know uh you know clicking away at
them at their heels we we ended up
doing a deal it was essentially a
more or less a merger of equals where we
did equity swap
created a new company and i became the
chairman of the combined company
um and so we put kind of two 600 person
teams together
um you know and became the the market
leader uh the kind of indisputed market
leader
um that after that merger we we then uh
ended up
getting an acquisition offer from a
company a joint venture of a south
african
and norwegian uh listed company uh that
was an all-cash deal
uh that was approved by the anti-trust
authorities at the end of november
uh 2020. so we're fresh off the the
acquisition there
and uh you know i'm i'm kind of done uh
you know and uh and now you know i'm on
to my next thing basically
so i want to zoom out a little bit and
just look at latin america in general uh
you're probably one of the people who
understands it's best that i know uh
talk a little bit just about the
technology scene there
and kind of how that has grown over the
last couple of years
even the last decade or so as as you
were operating in the
ecosystem yeah i mean things really have
hit an inflection point over the last
couple of years it's not a region that
got a lot of attention um in fact i
think it was an
it's an under-invested region you know
when you look at india
the the you know the gdp of of latin
america as a whole
is twice as large as india yet it
receives half of the venture funding so
you know this is it's a relatively
nascent market
i think over the last kind of four or
five years you know there's been a
handful of large
you know softbank dropping in in 2019
with their you know their innovation
fund five billion dollars you know
marcelo and the team they're saying you
know okay we're gonna re you know we're
gonna invest in the future of the region
i think leading up to that there was a
handful of interesting opportunities
but we've seen you know in brazil
there's the public markets are starting
to heat up
uh you know more companies are going
public we're starting to see liquidity
happen
and that's something that you know it
was kind of like you know brazil and
latin america is the
the market of the future and it's always
going to be that way that's
the kind of the joke about the region
but i think that you know with the
recent uh mega funding with you know
companies like newbank you know new bank
for those that don't know i'm sure most
people know is the largest you know
largest
one of the largest neo banks in the
world and you know they just
recently raised at a 25 billion dollar
market cap
that company started in 2013 so
incredible value created you know
sequoia was an early investor i think
wrote the first check along with
kazakh so that tends to kind of
reshape the region right and all of a
sudden uh it's not seen as kind of a
market that oh it might be interesting
in the future
um you know rapi is another example of
of a company that's
you know been incredibly successful you
know with their kind of
billion dollar landmark kind of funding
round uh
you know in the last year and a year and
a half ago so i think that all these
things have really
um you know helps put latin america on
the global stage
where it's seen as as you know as an
opportunity that it can can compete on
the on a global stage with you know the
top
kind of emerging markets and so that's
something that is a recent
advancement but uh you know the the
level of sophistication of investors
more angel investor angel operators
reinvesting back in the ecosystem
these are all kind of you know rising
tide type things that are lifting
all ships is when you talk about the
global stage is it
uh a thing where let's say latin america
is competing with
india or china or some other non-us
market or do you feel like
uh well that's acute narrative that
might not be necessarily as true as as
people think
yeah i think that you know i i think the
one thing that we're going to see over
the next
years is that you know there's a lot of
big companies that are expanding into
the region right like stripe
you know stripe is now like looking at
you know poking around with their
operations in brazil
and in latin america um and so
i think that given the proximity to the
u.s and the kind of the
the the time zone you know it's only you
know it's only a few hours you know it's
one hour ahead and
you know from new york right or two
hours ahead from from new york depending
on where you are in in
you know or so it's it's has a lot of
kind of connection with the u.s
um and so i think that you know i don't
think it'll necessarily compete in fact
i think
china has been an early entrant in the
region
um you know with the the recent
investment
it's not so recent now but a couple
years ago dd came in and bought
uh one of the ride-hailing you know
companies 99
and that minted the first uh latin
american unicorn of a tech startup
that was only a couple years ago since
then it's been a huge catalyst for the
region
there's been you know a lot more
activity so i think that
you know we look at these markets around
the world i think southeast asia is a
very interesting market
you know i i still think the region in
latin america is still a bit earlier
even than
in southeast asia so i don't think it'll
initially fight for dollars
um you know or or you know or bitcoins
but i think it's definitely an
opportunity
for you know for uh you know a lot of
global investors to start looking at the
region
given that you know it's it's a 700
person population
uh it's a you know a growing middle
class
and you know the income per capita is
higher than a lot of places in emerging
markets so
i think those are all variables that
will result in
massive interest in the region and we've
seen that over the last couple years
you're talking a little bit about kind
of venture capital's uh interest
and why they should be looking talk a
little bit about uh some of the success
stories
uh or the size of the funds and just you
know i think there's kind of uh safety
and numbers uh to some vcs uh whether
they should
act that way or not i just think that's
true and so how do you kind of think
about
the success stories that you can point
to uh that give them confidence that not
only are the demographics great not only
is there
kind of a large market but also there
are companies that have been successful
and can continue to do that and drive
returns for their funds
the last couple of years we've seen you
know
dozen now more than a dozen you know
billion plus
companies you know be created in the
region and so
you know vc dollars uh is a good sign
um exits is better right um so i think
we're still early on the exits
um but we've seen a handful of activity
there
and i think that you know when you look
at the you know the fact that you know
andreessen has
been doing more deals in the region and
you look at the top tier
excel has been there early um you know
you look at those kind of top tier
venture funds
you know i think that you know it's kind
of like you know don't ask me where you
think you know
let me see where you're putting your
money and so when you see
those come from those investors you know
starting to put more money into the into
the region
i think that's a strong signal but you
know there's been dozens of companies
that are you know raising
100 million dollar plus rounds um and i
think that
you know secondary transactions are
starting to happen things like that
where
those generate liquidity for early
investors um
and yeah i think that kind of kicks off
the cycle and so
you know in terms of numbers the numbers
are still relatively small i think last
year it was
a little over 5 billion went into vc but
it
doubled right and so when you've got 2x
growth
um you know that that's something that
is a strong indicator
of uh you know of kind of directionally
where things are headed
and when you couple that with the size
of the market um
you know and uh you know and kind of the
recent success stories
those are strong indicators that you
know probably some comfort in numbers
there
absolutely um you've got a whole bunch
of stuff going on
uh and so you've got this really unique
kind of understanding of both
the north american market and the latin
american market
is it a thing where the latin american
companies are simply taking ideas from
north america uh and then replicating
them and localizing for the local market
or there are companies that are actually
saying no we have unique problems here
and so we need to build
unique solutions that don't uh kind of
you know serve as copycats let's say
north american
ideas or companies you know it's a great
question and i get that question
sometimes
and and i like i like the question
because there's a couple things that it
allows me to address so first of all
the first wave of companies were like
similar to mine right like my company
was
a tropicalized version of zillow right
which is uh it's kind of a no-brainer
and it's
it's an obvious one where it's like okay
this works
uh why don't we kind of take this and
and and drop it into this large market
that's underserved right
um what i think that we're seeing now is
a new iteration of companies that are
solving intrinsic problems in the region
and
you know i'll come up with another
company that i actually invested in it
was the same
in the same space as real estate there's
two companies that i would like to
mention and in real estate
given that i'm pretty familiar with it
with the sector you know the first one
is quintuandar
uh you know they recently raised a 250
million dollar round led by softbank ga
was a
an investor in their kind of series b or
series c i don't remember
and that company they solved a very
specific problem
when you're renting an apartment and i
had this specific problem so i was able
to see
the problem early and that's why i wrote
an early check in this company
you know when you want to get an
apartment in order for you to rent an
apartment
you need a co-signer the co-center needs
to own
real estate in order for you to get a
apartment
i remember this problem because it was
extremely embarrassing when i had to go
to my wife's family
and say hey you know can can can your
dad help me
get an apartment because i'm you know
this person that doesn't have the
independence to be able to get an
apartment
so that's a massive pain point right i
mean think about how large the asset
class is
rentals across the region and so you
know we've seen
that model they came in and they built
kind of an insurance
you know play where they could kind of
assess the risk and they basically just
made it much easier
to reduce the friction for those that
wanted to rent um the same kind of on
the sale side you've got a company like
la house
they just raised a 35 million dollar
round from green spring
um and growing incredibly fast and
they're kind of combining
uh a bit more of like not just a
traditional kind of
you know for sale you know compass or a
zillow model in the us
they're actually combining a little bit
more inspired in a chinese company
called becky
uh bi b e i ke this
is a 70 billion dollar market cap in
china company it's it's an enormous
company
and it kind of combines a marketplace a
verticalized
solution for those you know looking to
sell you know buy and sell real estate
and so what starts in tropicalization
ends up becoming innovation and that's
something that i think the best
entrepreneurs do
because all the best companies solve
real local problems
and so i think we're starting to see a
level of maturity of the startups
uh it's not just you know mbas that are
you know coming down from harvard
and you know in copying an idea which is
more than welcome
um and but but there's more innovation
happening
uh you know where they're solving local
problems and attacking enormous markets
that way
so you've got a whole bunch of stuff
going on um
and you've got a book uh that you've
written uh you're doing a bunch of
investing maybe let's start with the
investing and then we'll get to the book
uh sure a little bit about the investing
activity that you're doing
um are you doing this personally do you
have a fund and kind of how you're
you're
uh looking uh to deploy capital in the
region
yeah so pomp uh it's funny like last
year i was sitting there waiting for the
anti-trust to approve our deal right
and as an entrepreneur this is
nerve-wracking right zero control
like what the hell is going to happen
like you know one of my buddies in
mexico got rid
his his deal got blocked by you know in
mexico and i'm like
he's in my ear like oh man i hope it
works and so
uh i was like okay i gotta do something
right i gotta get distracted
so i basically just like opened up you
know my dms on twitter
i opened up like you know all the
messages and i'm like if you're an
entrepreneur in latin america and you've
got a problem you're trying to solve
let me know and i'm going to provide
kind of some free advisory
work no strings attached and it was kind
of wild right i got like a lot of
people interested because i had some
degree of success in the region and
and so i took 150 phone calls from from
founders basically just
you know zoom and this was during the
pandemic right so like
you know there was a lot of interest and
a lot of uncertainty
and what happened after that was you
know i ended up connecting with two
other co-founders
who gina got hilf ran growth at duolingo
she was an early person there that took
them from three to two hundred million
users globally and then another friend
of mine who ran tech
at a venture back company in sao paulo
and the three of us
you know formed kind of a small team and
we basically just started helping these
founders
um no kind of strings attached we didn't
take any equity
um i ended up cutting a bunch of checks
in these companies because
you know we were organizing all these
sessions i wanted to tap my mentor
network
because i was very fortunate to have
amazing advisors that helped me over the
years
that i couldn't have done it without
them and it's a lonely journey as an
entrepreneur and so
we wanted to bring all this expertise
globally help these you know
very bright-eyed bushy-tailed founders
that are trying to build incredible
you know companies to transform the
region and what we
we ended up happening is we hosted
sessions on everything from fundraising
sales marketing products pr and
kind of magic happened all of a sudden
we had you know 40
companies they're all helping each other
mentors are helping them and so we
essentially build a community is what we
built
and i ended up writing 10 checks and
then i'm like okay how am i gonna let
people know about these companies you
know these are really interesting
companies so these are just angel checks
so i'm like i gotta call my friends uh
and let them know about these companies
and so give that here we are on zoom i
basically
hosted a an event uh you know call it a
demo day or whatever it is
and we had uh 17 entrepreneurs pitch
four minutes back to back
and we had uh you know originally it was
going to be a few of my friends
97 investors from all around the world
um you know listened in
ask questions and then you know some
funding kicked off after that so
it was a good way to mark up some of my
angel investments uh and
a great opportunity to source the best
deals
uh given that i have a pretty strong
network in the region so that kind of
organically happened
and then we ended up like this sounds
like it could be a business
uh we haven't really decided what the
business model is going to be yet
we're really focused on building the
social capital first
um but we're basically we do have a fund
that's a
rolling fund uh you can go to
fund.latitude.com
it's latitude without the e because it's
in spanish so funds.latitude
with no e.com and that describes the the
fund
we're really looking for uh operator
people you know
similar to kind of you know what you
know what you've got going and people
that can add value
um and are interested in the region so
uh it's a
great way for a little r d throw a small
check in
you know get you know free r d uh
hopefully you know that it generates
some returns
for you and uh and learn about the
market so that's something we just
launched
in fact this is the first time i'm
publicly speaking about it so um
you know uh i guess uh now is a good
good time as any right
we will uh we'll make sure to drive a
couple of people there just don't yell
at me if
there's too much traffic i heard you
know a few people bob
uh let's talk about your book uh that
you've recently written as well
uh what what is kind of the idea going
on there and then where's that at
yes so the book uh you know it's it's
called viva the entrepreneur my company
was viva real uh and it's you know
founding
scaling and raising venture capital in
latin america and we launched last week
uh we hit the number one bestseller um
in the u.s
in the venture category which kind of
blew me away because
when i saw it passing venture deals from
bradfeld the book that i literally
read on the way to visit all the vcs on
sand hill road
like you know that kind of blew my mind
but it just shows that there's more
interest in the region
um and so that book yeah is live on
amazon um
you know and uh you know it's it's
really the book that i wish i had when i
started i would say
linda rottenberg who is the founder of
endeavor endeavor is a global
organization
40 countries um you know they're they're
they've all the largest companies around
the world that are in tech outside of
the valley
uh are part of this network to 2 500
entrepreneurs
you know billions of dollars of value
created and there's
the support network for that um you know
she she was kind enough to write my
forward
and her her description was it was the
hard thing about hard things for latin
america
i think it was a bit of an overstatement
and i and any anytime i'm being in
in the senses of ben ben horowitz it's
pretty kind of a humbling uh
humbling statement but uh you know i
when i read that book
it also kind of really affected me
because i felt you know the loneliness
of being on the journey as an
entrepreneur and so i tried to write the
book that i wish i had when i started
talk a little bit um and i think you
cover some of this in the book just
around how important the people are
in the region uh and now that there's
been more and more folks who have been
successful
i know there's wences and a couple of
others maybe talk just about how
important uh
that network is and how that's growing
from kind of a people perspective
yeah so you know this is an important
part of the region right and i mean it's
something that we take for granted in
like
you know hotbeds like you know like the
bay area or new york where there's like
this ecosystem right and it's like
you've got success then they people
reinvest back in the ecosystem and like
that stuff is that it's early days like
we're in diapers in latin this is just
like this is
this is day one right and so when you've
got people like you know
success stories i mentioned endeavor
endeavor um
wences was one of the first endeavor
entrepreneurs actually um and so
you know linda was you know they call
her the chica the crazy girl
because she's from you know from new
york and she's like i think that
there's incredible entrepreneurs outside
of you know silicon valley
and so she went down to argentina she
discovered wences
uh wences at the time was launching he
launched the first isp
internet service provider in latin
america from argentina when he was like
24
um and then soon after you know that
didn't work out he kind of got
kind of moved out of that and he ended
up you know starting patagon the first
kind of
bank for the region and you know she was
trying to raise money to like support
these entrepreneurs and
everyone was like latin america like
there's no entrepreneurs in latin
america like that's
that's absurd you know like that's not
going to work and
you know they ended up helping wences uh
linda
actually kind of helped her find her you
know find his co uh in fact
her assistant ended up getting married
to so you know to wences uh
bell and winces ended up getting married
from from endeavor and so
you know 18 months later wences sold
patagone for 750 million dollars in an
all-cash deal to banco santander
and this is like you know a month or two
before the
the dot-com crash investors obviously
made a pile of money
and all of a sudden they're like hey do
you have any more 26 year olds or 27
year olds that are
better that are doing any interesting
stuff and so that um
i tell that story you know and wences
ended up being becoming an angel
investor in our company
and if only i i'd listened to him back
in the day when he was
you know talking about bitcoin and and
bringing that to you know
to the masses uh you know i uh you know
so
i think that we need more success
stories like that and we need more
people reinvesting in the ecosystem
and so i think that you know that's kind
of we're at a
an inflection point there because now
there's more companies
and so i you know i'm very grateful for
wences and other people
like him you know mickey malka from you
know from ribbit capital
people like that that you know they
paved the way in the region and
they became advisers and mentors to me
and investors
and so i kind of look at this as an
opportunity to pay it forward
um you know i feel almost the
responsibility to you know reach back
and kind of pull up the next generation
of iconic
uh you know founders that are building
incredible businesses
in a market that is enormous with a lot
of friction points
absolutely and it feels a lot like uh
you know once you
are kind of in this together right and
you're building a new region when it
comes
from a technology landscape uh and
somebody makes it they feel very
obligated and loyal to turn around
not only say thank you to the people who
helped them but also to kind of help the
next generation
of entrepreneurs and it feels like that
kind of community
uh is definitely present in silicon
valley and is now kind of becoming
present
uh throughout latin america as well i i
think that's a
perfectly said and uh you know it's uh
it's part of my
my conviction that over the next decade
this is what i what i want to do
i want to help elevate the ecosystem and
i think there's incredible talent
and an incredible opportunity and so uh
it's something that i feel is
part of my responsibility and i think
it's an incredible opportunity obviously
it's not charity work at all before
we get into the rapid fire questions to
wrap up uh the big you know kind of uh
um development if you will over the last
12 18 months was
covid and this whole idea of now
everyone is sitting at home
uh i used to do all of these interviews
in person now i do them all remotely
uh you as well rather than go meet
people in person you now
sit at home and and do a lot of this how
has that
helped latin america right is it
something where now
uh it isn't as important for investors
to get on a plane and travel there
they can kind of do things through uh
the internet and so that's
actually kind of increased accessibility
to the region entrepreneurs and
investors both get more comfortable
uh kind of fundraising online just what
have you seen uh kind of post covid
really hitting
um in terms of it being a beneficial
thing for uh for the latin american
ecosystem
i would say i can think of three things
first of all the fundraising no doubt um
you know this is opening up a world you
know just like we did our demo day and
we had 97 investors our last one we had
180 something investors
from all over the world particularly at
pre-seed right and seed and precede
where it's just like you're bet you're
betting on the team you're betting on
the market opportunity
um you know those are that's opened up a
wide
array of opportunities kind of connected
to that but a separate point
you know we look at the you know kind of
the
network of people that are available to
help and advise and
you know so you can get an early angel
investor that's located anywhere
and and then they can also add value to
what you're doing you know i was very
fortunate to find those two early
investors that
not only bring money more importantly
they you know they added value and could
help me with
kind of the strategy fundraising you
know uh and and exec you know ideas on
execution
because they had experience so we're
seeing this right now with latitude
where we built this amazing mentor
network
and we have we have you know mentors in
london we have mentors in
you know across europe and in you know
in in
in the states that people that actually
think of all the incredible talented
incredibly talented people that you know
have gone through places like facebook
or
google or you know amazon that you know
uh you know luis one of our mentors is
that zillow he runs product at zillow
he's from
you know argentina grew up in venezuela
and now he's a mentor
sharing all of his experience in product
management at a company like zillow
right
so and and these people have an
intrinsic
interest to like you know they had an
opportunity to come to the states
they made it big time a lot of ways and
they want to they want to
lift up their you know the ecosystem so
i think that that is kind of the second
point of you know there's a connection
there
the last thing i'll say is that talent
is anywhere now right
i mean i i'm building this next thing
there's there's seven of us half of the
team
you know the three of the seven and i
haven't actually met in person
on my team right and you know i feel
like i know that i'm working seven
months with them and
we're just as close as we would be in an
office so wherever you stand on the kind
of remote versus office
you know debate um i think it's
incontrovertible that
we're in a position now where like
companies are being built and
and to add to that you know there's big
companies in the valley that are
starting to hire engineering talent
uh because it's it's flat now the
world's flat you know i remember reading
that book
you know from from you know freeman uh
you know friedman back in
you know 2004 and i'm like the world is
flat and
that is it couldn't be more true today
and so you're seeing
you know engineering talent from
argentina buenos aires
building products you know for companies
in the states
and that's just i think you know we're
seeing a decentralization of the silicon
valley and the silicon valley now is in
the cloud right
i uh i i love it and i think you're dead
on uh and the people who recognize this
earlier rather than later will
will greatly benefit for sure um asking
three questions to everyone to uh to
finish up and then you'll get to ask me
one
uh to take us home uh the first is
what's the most important book that
you've ever read and you cannot say your
own
um you know i guess i'm gonna say
business book like
the most influential book on my kind of
trajectory is like i remember
uh walking the streets of bogota
colombia you know i was an
english teacher you know like didn't
have much going on but i knew i wanted
to do something
um you know in real estate i would look
up at these big skyscrapers in in boleta
and i had on my my ipod at the time i
had the book
uh the long tail um you know by chris
anderson
and it was like boom like oh this this
whole concept of like
you know the long tail the head like you
know and that was when i had kind of
that that
contributed the idea of real estate
getting all the inventory
like when i started no one had inventory
like it was like
you know they would just market a
limited number of properties
and so i went in and i got all the
listings and then all of a sudden we
built the largest marketplace with the
most liquidity
and i wouldn't have done it if i didn't
read that book so i would have to i
would have to give a nod to chris
anderson
in that book um and so that's that's
probably
a lot of other books it's a tough
question but uh that would be the one
that probably had the most impact on my
career
that's great answer uh second question
is more personal
uh sleep this comes from our friends
over at uh eight sleep
i used to be five six hours sleeper now
more like eight or nine hours and
they've got these uh thermoregulated
beds that essentially you can make it
hot or cold
uh i basically sleep like i am in
antarctica at this point
and uh and it's much much better for me
from a sleep perspective
what's your sleep schedule and how has
that changed over the years especially
uh when you were running a business to
uh to today not running
um kind of that fast-growing technology
company
well it's it's a great question it's
something that i i have an internal
struggle with uh like i think a lot of
entrepreneurs
do where there's the you know the it's
just so
it's so building a company is daunting
it's exciting
i like to say that your best day and
your worst day is the same day
and so it's just an emotional coaster
and so i think that i'm
not the poster child for this uh i wish
i was
better at at sleep and i'm it's just
something that's a priority so i need to
maybe check out the product that you
mentioned because
i'm i'm working on that on my own i
think that i go through kind of uh
you know swings here with you know with
with my sleep patterns
i try to get you know a good chunk of
sleep and i try to get to bed relatively
early
um i find that when i'm going through an
exciting moment like with this book
uh i'm i'm we're talking on a few hours
of sleep
and it's because i'm it's because i'm
i'm excited about what's going on
uh but i am trying to rein in the kind
of hyperactivity of my mind and the
excitement of everything that's going on
and actually i wrote about this a little
bit in my book so um
you know and i'm not i'm not the expert
on it but
i have i strive to do what you've been
able to accomplish there
because i just know how how important it
is as as you know someone to be
productive i'm a convert man
i'm a convert of the sleep religion i
know that it's uh it's kind of like
crossfit
or uh uh intermittent fasting or
something else right if you do it you
gotta talk about it but i gotta say that
uh
especially for somebody who uh who you
know was flying all over the place and
doing all this crazy stuff
now all of a sudden if i don't get eight
hours uh i feel it like it feels weird
it's one of those things you're like how
did i ever live like this
um so i'll send you some links to uh to
eight sleep and everything
please do please do man i'm i'm like
it's an important one and like
it's kind of like the people that i envy
like that meditate
and i'm just like damn i know it's so
good i gotta you know
and and i'm like here on the sidelines
like you know
once in a while i'll dip in and i'll
like kind of get a hit of it and then
you know i'm i'm but i'm not i'm not
fully there yet but i'm just a work in
progress man i still got some years left
and i'm uh
one percent every day hopefully i hear
you i hear you
all right last question that you get to
ask me one is aliens are you a believer
or a non-believer
man uh hearing elon on clubhouse the
other day
uh you know with his uh statements
around uh
you know if if there was he would know
about it um if
you know but that being said i think i'm
gonna have to um
i'm gonna have to to go with the drake
equation here uh
and and you know i'm not talking about
the i'm not talking about the hip-hop
star here
where well you know uh you know the
number of civilizations in our galaxy
with you know which communication might
be possible is too enormous for me to
deny
and so you know i'm gonna have to go
with uh yeah they exist
and uh you know it's a big place so i'm
i'm on that i'm on that train i'm on
that intergalactic train
um i'm right there with you i don't know
if we'll come in contact but uh but i
definitely think that
they exist uh what uh what one question
you have for me to uh to wrap this up
yeah man i would love to know one what
was your
i got if i can be selfish here and ask
two questions uh of course
what was your first investment that you
made ever
and why did you make it
i mean the very first investment i ever
made was definitely in myself
uh which is kind of a cheesy shitty
answer uh
i was just buying books and all that
kind of stuff um
the first financial investment i ever
made
uh it's gonna sound really bad we can we
can count we can count you know baseball
cards
uh yeah that's that also counts to be
honest
i don't remember like a financial
investment in terms of
uh like a stock or anything like that i
don't think it was stocks the first
thing i can remember
um this is wild but uh after i came back
from iraq i was 21 years old
and uh in the spring after i came
back somehow i got into uh foreign
currency trading
and uh i had a hot hand for
uh for about six months and uh
i turned like you know like 9k to 72 000
i was like
well who needs a job i'm gonna do this
when i leave college like
it's amazing and then got cocky uh uh
over the summer i went and did
a uh an internship in new york city was
trading on my phone like an idiot and
you know kind of
the classic you know day trading
nonsense and so very quickly realized
like hey let me take my uh
take my my measly profits that are left
and get the hell out of this thing
uh but that's the first time that like
uh i remember like really taking like
capital and saying hey i'm gonna go and
and uh and risk it to uh to get a gain
um and uh and frank i'm thankful for it
right it's like
it taught me all the good things and the
bad things all in a condensed period of
time and uh
i haven't done too much trading ever
since then i hear you man you got you
gotta
you gotta be long uh the currency
currency game it's like that first taste
of blackjack and then
and then and you you don't wanna make a
living out of that
um my second question is
so pomp i i started a podcast uh you
know i think you know you're a big
inspiration and all the content you put
out and
you know i'm trying to take take a page
out of your book
um so i start a podcast and i after
listening to a lot of your episodes i
want to know what the story is
on what's the origin story on bang bang
i got a bad memory i guess because i
don't remember
you you just you just you just knew that
it would it would hit i
you know what i'd love to you know if
you don't have one that's okay but
it is it was it was a story it's a
consistency thing like i knew that
if i started it every time uh with the
same thing like it would eventually just
get
you know like basically steered into
people's minds and uh i think that
part of it is just like you know other
people are like uh hello welcome to
you know whatever uh thing and like
that's just not me so i was like
like how are we gonna start this thing
and so i actually tell you a good story
not to do specifically with bang bang
but uh for people who listen to the
podcast uh when it was off the chain
now if you listen to the intro um the
very first intro i ever recorded
uh was one shot so the guys were helping
me with it uh they basically were like
hey here's the music
and i if i remember correctly i think i
had the i had headphones and i was
listening to the music
and uh as it was going i had a
microphone in front of me
and so i just one shot was like you know
what's up guys
uh uh whatever and in it i was like
uh the best podcasting crypto
and so when i got done they they were
like dude we haven't even recorded a
single episode yet
and i was like yeah but we're the best
obviously like kind of like joking
but they were like uh should we like
roll with this and i was like
if we say we're the best we're gonna be
the best like we're gonna run with it
and so like i think it's just this
element of uh
you gotta have um you gotta have some
like line uh or element of confidence
and like when you're gonna go do things
at the same time you don't wanna be
arrogant and so like that one kind of
toes the line between arrogance and
confidence
but i do think that uh there's this
thing of like bang bang i'm gonna make
it a thing right and so
i just did it a couple of times the next
thing you know people started leaving
comments you know bang bang whatever and
it's like okay like
this is gonna work the uh the crazy
thing though is there's a couple of
other people who have been like i've say
i say that i'm like look man we must all
be family or something then because i
guess
you know we all arrived at the same
thing but i'm not i'm not stopping so
uh so yeah yeah yeah
you you own that you own that um yeah i
i after my first season i just finished
my first season i was like man i need a
bang bang
what's my bang bang and so my mine i
started my second season
and it's uh it's super like you know for
me right like my my audience is
vamos la tam that's my that's my you
know
i'm like let's go latin america
so so that's my bang bang man i i love
it and the whole podcast is in uh
spanish
well actually i started off doing it in
portuguese um
because i was in brazil and uh and then
i i
i changed over to english so but all of
my audience is basically
connected to latin america or interested
in latin america so it's spanish and
portuguese you know i i speak spanish
and portuguese but we do it in english
because
obviously that's the audience you want
to reach anyway right
yeah makes uh makes a ton of sense so
yeah nice
bang bang i like it all right listen i
really really appreciate you taking the
the time to do this brian uh where can
we send people to find the book or find
you on the internet
sure sure so uh the book is on amazon uh
it's aviva the entrepreneur
uh so you can you know look for that um
and
audible's coming out the audiobook
coming out in the next month or two um
which i read which is a long period
a long process so i'm on twitter you can
find me on twitter
um linkedin and clubhouse are the kind
of the main the main areas where i uh
i'm on the social social web so uh yeah
man this is fun i i really appreciate
the conversation and uh it's it's an
honor to be on here man
i appreciate you taking that time to do
it you've absolutely been killing it and
i think it's important for people to
understand
uh kind of latin america and the startup
investing scene there so thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
and we will definitely have to do to get
in the future absolutely man
thanks a lot